good evening everybody on a cold and
rainy night a warm welcome to the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences I'm John bloom one of the three
governors in the short films and feature
animation branch along with John
Lasseter and Bill kroyer and the chair
of the branch we're here tonight to
screen this year's Oscar shorts in
animation and live-action and meet our
nominated film makers as I look around
the sold-out event I'm so glad you're
here hell I'm so glad the shorts are
still a part of the Academy Awards 12
years ago when the branch first elected
me to the Academy Board of Governors
this annual public screening was one of
the few places that non Academy members
could see these short gems today that is
far from the case these shorts are ever
more widely available around the world
in fact short films are now in the midst
of a genuine renaissance with enormous
interest in shorts online in fact one of
the animated nominees were going to see
tonight was available for free online
recently and listen to this logged 13
million views
this year marks the 80th consecutive
year that the Academy has awarded Oscars
to shorts and with good reason we've had
a record-shattering 181 eligible
submissions with 55 animated shorts and
126 live action in contention by the way
this year for the first time ever at the
suggestion of the branch executive
committee the Academy has provided all
6,000 Oscar voters with a DVD of these
nominated shorts to foster greater
participation and from what I'm hearing
Academy members are ecstatic and
speaking of making the nominated shorts
available to a wider audience that
continues to at a record pace last year
the National theatrical release grossed
over a million seven hundred thousand
dollars better than half the nominated
foreign and Doc features it ranked for
the year a hundred and eighty ninth of
all releases and 44 out of the top 50
indie releases and continued our
phenomenal growth rate of better than
thirty-three percent annual increase
pretty good we guesstimate that last
year more than 400,000 people paid to
see the nominated shorts via the
theatrical release video on demand and
iTunes and this year of course is even
stronger with a theatrical release
crossing the million five hundred
thousand dollar threshold yesterday with
over 400 theatrical bookings set
nationwide in all major markets proof of
the solid and significant interest in
the Oscar shorts brand nominated shorts
which we view as the cream of the crop
in the exploding world of short films
and as I preach every year this is only
the beginning consider this with 400,000
paid viewers compared to Oscar ceremony
ratings of 40 million there remains room
for continued enormous growth if we are
at one percent now just imagine the
potential and come on admit it the Oscar
show is more fun when you've seen the
shorts and have a rooting interest not
to mention office pools and as you will
soon see again this year our nominated
shorts are terrific and very special
which brings us back to tonight and our
extraordinary master of ceremonies here
to lead the q and A's with our talented
nominees he has been a veteran of Wes
Anderson's talented troops since
Rushmore providing voiceover and wes is
animated the fantastic mr fox and
appearing now in moonrise kingdom to say
nothing of starring and co-writing the
Digi lling limited that along with his
roles in I Heart Huckabees Marie
Antoinette slackers and shop girl but he
also has been active in shorts most
notably the outstanding hotel chevalier
also written and directed by wes and
starring along with Natalie Portman he's
smart he's funny and he's here with us
tonight as our host please join me in
welcoming Jason Schwartzman
hello thank you thank you John thank you
all for coming tonight I just want to
say that this is a beautiful evening
because all of you want to be here all
of you have chosen to come and make this
an important occasion and celebrate this
achievement with the filmmakers who are
all here tonight so please when you
applaud right now for them they all hear
it and feel that and I think it's super
super incredible because a lot of a lot
of the directors if not all of them i'm
not sure but we'll ask them later we'll
be seeing their films on a screen such
as this with the sound system for the
first time ever so that's really
exciting and before i begin a strange
speech or analogy i just wanted to thank
John and Ellen for having me tonight and
for everyone who works with them who are
super nice and I have treated me like a
governor
just for tonight but I would like to say
that I do i do love short films animated
live action I love short stories I love
short songs I love short phone calls I
love most most things that are short and
I think that the reason I gravitate to
things like that too short conversations
or short films or stories is that they
can be while there are two kinds there
are kinds that are perfect little pop
gems perfectly written stories movies
that have everything you need that tells
a complete story and you feel that was
perfect bleeb it built then there is
another type of perfectly built thing
that I love just as much which is almost
the opposite of that which is mysterious
and impressionistic and makes you have
to come up with the beginning or the end
and provide your own imagine context for
the film and I liken it to this type of
thing like walking down the street and
you overhear someone say something like
well I'll never do that again and you
keep walking they pass you in your
thinking I wonder what they'll never do
again maybe they will never you know
talk to that person again or maybe
they'll you never go back there again
but ultimately they you know they could
just be talking about like eating a
grilled cheese sandwich but because it's
short and it's just a snippet of
something you can imagine it now the
other kind that we were talking about is
the grilled cheese sandwich and it's the
best grilled cheese sandwich in the
world perfectly compressed and grilled
so I want to thank everyone for making
both types of short things and and and
it is an honor and I was just downstairs
and I met everyone and I loved it
because everybody
everybody gets along down there and
everyone likes each other and I think
that this room you coming these
directors and writers and producers for
making these things these are these are
creative endeavors that can only be made
if the people who are making them have
to make them and want to make them and
love making them and they can only be
sustained and be loved if people come to
see them so this is a night where
everybody really is a community and
everybody is helping each other and we
are all friends and and we are all short
so I would like to say thank you and I
love you I love you and I now encourage
you to put on your 3d glasses and we are
going to start the event and when it is
over take them off because the other
ones aren't intended to be viewed with
3d glasses but you can leave them on if
you want to get if you want to go with
that goodbye hey Barry Chris our
projectors up there give you a hand for
a Barry Chris our projectors and let's
roll it
you
you
what
Oh
you
you
all right I'd like to invite everybody
up who is a part of these films would
you please step forward
that's awesome congratulations
congratulations awesome hi bye
congratulations hey all right here are
nominees
I'm gonna start by asking just a general
question but I'll start I'll go far i'll
start with you John will come this way
but but to all of you why did you choose
the style of of animation that that you
present is nitin and how did it help you
tell the story um thanks everybody for
coming out first of all um the paper man
I meant I'm I'm a CG guy you know um I i
was at pixar for ten years and I i love
that whole renaissance and animation
that's been happening it's really like
the Golden Age of CG right now and tron
was a huge it made a huge impact on me
as a kid but when i moved down here to
LA and and started working at disney i
think i was really enchanted by the
drawings again and trying to figure out
a way to bring that back into the bring
that line that expressive line and hand
of the artist back into the the image
again resulted in trying to do that
hybrid technique of bringing the two of
them together and I if to me it's a way
it comes together in a way that I've
never really seen before and it's really
the amazing engineering knowledge at
Disney that made that happen so I'm head
over heels we had this concept of course
what you just saw which could
potentially have read I think if we had
done it in 2d vort of with more of a
dollhouse approach I think it could have
I think hit the audience more on the
level of an idea or a concept and I
really wanted it to have a magical
realist feel with that this universe
with upward facing gravity was kind of a
world that you could immerse the
audience in and stop motion has this
really great intensely textural quality
with this focus on these miniatures it
rates the natural textures that they
have automatically there's no extra work
you have to do to get that and I think
that that makes the world that these
characters live in that much more
tactile and and it lends this reality to
the world that they live in I'm with
fresh guacamole uh you know I just like
making things with my hands basically
that's the thing I mean I love the idea
that you can put anything in front of a
camera and photograph it and move it a
little bit and create the illusion of
movement and that's just an exciting
process to me so in this film I animated
my own hands making you know guacamole
and then there's also obviously
animation with objects as well happening
there so it's kind of a combination of
the form of pixilation which is
animating the human body and just a
traditional form of stop-motion with
inanimate objects which is really one of
the oldest art forms in cinema um it's
been around for 100 so years and I just
love that that immediacy of being able
to say here's the object let's bring it
to life with Adam and dog I really want
to describe Eden in a different kind of
sense and I think 3d animation and stop
motion animation and 2d animation
they're not just different styles but
they really describe different worlds
and they describe different
physicalities for example 3d animation i
think is very exact in its portrayal of
dimension and the space as opposed to 2d
animation which i think is there is a
metaphysical impressionistic not exact
quality to it and with describing eat it
Eden that's something that I wanted to
do that it was there was something
metaphysical about this place that it
was more of a mental state rather than a
real stage and that it was this strong
impressionist equality of drawing that I
felt like lended itself better to that
world so well under the Maggie Simpson
short it was originally gonna be live
action but you know while jokes didn't
really play we we've decided to go in a
direction more pantomime which we do in
small areas on the simpsons but this is
we decided to go a totally Phantom I'm
to try something a little different and
also from obviously we own pantomime
Maggie's a logical choice because she
doesn't say too much and also from her
perspective which gave us a location
that we borrowed from a show from way
back when the main difference is we were
trying things in 3d and so we thought
something you know like running down
hallways would be great for 3d yeah
you're right Hey well can I ask you to
John and David because your films you
know we're screen theatrically in you
know many many thousands and thousands
of theaters at what point in the process
do you find out that you are going to
have that you know that that you're
going to be attached to a film and a
theater like that how does it affect the
work and why do you think studios do
that I think it's great that they do
that what is it what do you what do you
love about it uh well for me when they
they're like okay go do paper man but
don't worry about that it's going to get
released anymore don't get ahead of
yourself killed mundo and which is
probably the best thing for me because I
worrying about that is the last thing I
should be worrying about yeah so I think
it went emerged the way it did and kind
of started to really gel then there was
kind of rumors about it and then finally
they announced it at one of the company
meanings which was really exciting
because that the exposure it gets a soul
just immense from a theatrical release
especially if it's Disney doing the
releasing but what was the other part of
the
well wasn't even that great it wasn't as
it was a your answer was better than the
second part of my question so we can
leave it right there okay beautiful we
started this process in this film two
years ago roughly around then I was in a
meeting with Jim Brooks and can i bring
up mention three the writers who are
here yes Al Jean and David merkin and
Michael price right there stand up boy
let's just stand up your baby pig guys
well they don't want to stay okay I'm
not gonna stand up oh wait so we'd at
the stat the beginning then we didn't we
were talking about theatrical release
per se it was sort of vaguely mentioned
that maybe would happen and we worked on
it for while I worked on it for about a
little less than three months getting
the real together we like some of it
some things we weren't crazy about it
and so we got is very excited so we put
it on the shelf for a while we're so
excited about it and and nothing much
happened for a while week every now and
then something might be happening when I
quite okay and then in March things
started picking up again and they were
because a one of a film ice age 4 was
coming out and they thought it might be
nice to attach to that so that meant we
had to do it in about two months so Wow
well you know we can that seems fast oh
it's yeah some fast um what about you
two now you tell me about because you're
the only two people up here that two
people representing one movie tell me
about how your creative process and
working together I'm head over heels is
it like it was in the movie
uh sometime place it that way well foula
was the producer and I was the writer
director of the film and we also have a
huge showing of our crew here in the
house actually and if I mean film is a
collaborative process and an animation
in some ways you and more so because you
don't even have a single actor who can
take credit for the performance I mean
that split across the animator the voice
actor and the character designer and I
don't know I think working together as
from the directors point of view working
with the crew is wonderful because it
means you don't really have to generate
all the ideas you can focus on your
responsibilities which I think as a
director is to craft the experience of
the audience and and and so foully you
in in many ways you were I think the
that test audience many times I would
come to you with some idea and and you'd
say that doesn't work try again and so
it was great I mean photo was yeah what
are you talk about it oh come on I'm
talking I'm talking and what Tim came to
me with the concept of the right way up
upside down world and so from there he
actually had an ending first so we
developed his story backwards so we
workshopped a script for about four
months although he didn't actually write
a script it was more beach eat so we
workshop for that for about four months
and together which was quite interesting
and then from there we obviously we
start working with our team of people
such amazing people they are and all
students as well and we then spent the
next four to five months sorting out the
set bills and the Papa built and then
from there we animated for about six
months Wow so it was quite hefty so from
come what is that yeah what
from concept to delivery of the actual
film we had 15 months if we do if we
didn't do it within that time we would
not have graduated so uh why wiki very
looking I'm happy you guys all you all
graduated everybody graduated that's
great everybody made it out congratulate
that's it that's great um pet PES I have
a question so in your one like you said
earlier referring to pixelation you you
know your arms those are your arms are
in the are in the short what is that
like physically to on your body to do
you to be stop-motion happy that I take
it seemed you know the process of
keeping something and then moving it in
just the tiniest increments on a human
body it seems like it would be very
difficult to do can you talk about how
you did that I mean I think it's just I
had to be a statue it's like one of
those people that's you know stay on the
street and they hold their pose yeah I
just had to do that with my hands and it
was just hours and hours of standing
there you know recreating a natural
movement you know the way that a knife
is you know brought down on a cutting
board or you know how you manipulate
very specific ways to manipulate an
avocado and you know it's it's hard I
mean it's time cuz in time consuming but
also physically taxing in the sense that
you know sometimes I have to skip meals
and you know you're like shaking and
you're like I you know there's a couple
times all you can't do this I I think it
stop motion but it's but
that is not that's not right but it's
really difficult because if you leave to
go get lunch it's very very very
difficult to get that exact look you
know point back to continue a shot so
it's kind of like we would just go on
these like enormous binge lunches and
then just come back to the studio and
just like shoot for like nine hours who
is we how many people are I have a 1 ko
animator his name's Dylan Marquis here
Dylan raise your hand stand up say hello
hey Dylan congratulations and and and
this was like putting two guys in a
locker room for four months so um you
know so so yeah so basically you know
those were my hands and and Dylan and I
had to form you know kind of form a bond
really you know where he you know can
know exactly what I'm hoping to achieve
and obviously I can talk the whole time
but but you know there's certain things
that I just can't do holding my hands
there the whole time because I have the
knife in my hands and and you know he's
gotta reach under there and like just
move like the monopoly house just a
little bit you know to you know make it
look right so it's pretty angry pretty
incredible and you don't big I you have
a question when I looked at the credits
again noticing tonight you see so many
names repeated and the feeling I got and
from what i read i read a little little
bit about is the film took many years to
make right yeah um like five two and a
half but mainly that's basically half
yes yeah um all right I'm gonna round it
up so he took him five years to make
this movie
and um but and this and this honestly is
a question I don't mean to seem naive
and please and everyone else get answer
to if you care to but you know this is a
film that takes a long time to make and
you're making it during off hours and
things how do you can you talk about how
you keep the people with you working for
that long on something and it's talking
about what I was saying earlier but like
you have to love something these movies
get made because the people you love
them and they have to be made and it's
about like friendship and people all
working together can you just talk about
like it's the actual process of how you
keep people for so long working on
something um that's a really good
question thank you well the answer is is
you know they have to work on it because
there are my friends right there's no
other I mean they're all here I don't
think there is any other way so all
right I don't know what else is Baxter
out there sorry Baxter no he's not here
that's the one guy yeah well I don't
know what else friendship means other
than someone working for you that means
the same thing to me so but it doesn't
go the other way around so it's only
yeah yeah I'm an only child by the way
yeah um oh yeah Glen Glen Keane for
those of you don't know Glen Keane and
James Baxter kind of huge legendary
names in the animation world and
unfortunately they're not my buddy buddy
friends although I would like to call
them best friends but they they pretty
much like everyone else on the film they
kind of volunteered to work on the film
and everyone did as much as they could
as much time allowed like little bits
here and there but without them I
couldn't have done it and so the key was
to not pressure them or push them too
much and buy them lots of lunches and be
really nice and yeah occasionally cry
very occasionally as my weapon so well
anyways I just that that concludes the
animated interview symposium and there's
a ten-minute break where you can leave
you can stay you can leave or you could
stay with me here we can just talk for
the next ten minutes up here will turn
up the mics and just talk but please do
return because we will get to the live
action shorts
keep an event so tough that is mighty
low budget Dumanis I was not
economically go yeah yeah but she's at
hakkasan I how r oh I saw the local from
the roof collection Carla but new gonna
tell about their way Rohtang como
cambiar de la Luna
awesome wika hope you're welcome janta
I'm gonna be super bad into Bala a super
y necesita de su bueno yo hago tasuku
buena Subin dirt abhilasha piranha a
holics anti-shake necessary madre ah
soomaaliya a hot a da hospital so shaggy
netaji nagar CJ Jeep yeah come on Monica
and is it
booked out of anoka huge Ellen vesicle o
Mara qatan says oh costa la Tasha Malek
a clear Somali silicon oh ha ha acaba
bahama Salaam
I said request can be like nostalgia men
who cheat myself over suppose got a
mulligan Hathaway we're mother a
chocolate contractor look who we have
put you together Willa guess I say aha
our sister Baylor on a check animal LOL
a sack of tamiya what else can you say
but don't have a case about the e karam
of you exactly that's what dr. Mallin
took ha ok yeah they cheated belmont oh
and don't killer our human together but
now watch what is that indigent acting
super yankee rookie Mahad you get that
guru
that's it come here so comma take my
offer get the rest o seer probably am
home below the Beretta also claims of
copyright to be sick grandmother
massapequa can you open hello terrible
accident drunkenness are a lie ahead
alida alina i send us your house over my
app in Berlin ayaka mucha mucha tarea
and balawai aku submit Barbara Birk la
la semana de escanear so messy mya been
necesito who had blue hair lucky ban kar
liya hai
money better than that
you
when they get in
Oh
y
dr. momma Dee Dee Ann doctor who died
mejor adeje lasagna udhayam como hacer
mas OB he conned often digga dr. Valen
bday yeah hey tomorrow airport Abacha
direct and africa who says no llama de
pero me faltan jacaranda gautama
Karmanos me oh there play for me yeah
grows mahadji october no sirven the
story to necto pondo serie de notas de
la sombra de mis vandy get a coma
amplification e te caigas Durie agra
mijo y lavando si voy de gallo sabahi
wafik logically
bosnia grows hard to become cocoa Yoda
Pensacola madam na mara blonde hot Ibaka
what now mandatory homos Cassie heart
suction
to co polymer is in it maja and hijo de
faker KD mom slower yeah going garbage y
de Casta here on toes animator sasa home
which is rakesh and odm attention
yeah come out of me show me what's wrong
hey what's the crop you want to go
what's wrong I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
all right i watch I didn't hey I didn't
spend the money Sophia I have the money
right here all right I do not spend the
money where's your mom say about tell me
that she doesn't talk about would you
please stop walking I went to get these
flip books okay I I just thought maybe
you'd enjoy him I ok listen I did not
spend any of the money i didn't spend a
dollar this money and I don't lie all
right I I don't lie I just thought maybe
everything because because I used to
live there okay I used look I'm sorry
all right I didn't think I shouldn't
approach me I'm not clear-headed I just
like thought maybe you'd like to see
these would you like to see one
you see
she got shot by an arrow yeah you know
she dies like Looney Tunes you know but
she always comes back to life seats up e
always comes back how did you do all
this I don't do it well I don't know I
guess I was bored I have a gameboy a
frog or whatever is your plan I didn't
know the game else I don't know I know
it you know I know it you look brighter
yeah I know Fragger I know it you know
bragger yeah I know it's amazing can we
not be in the cold anymore please
favorite number three favorite color me
who's the accident what X the exit where
he never saw me again it doesn't matter
I want to know what does it matter you
know what the leading cause of lung
cancers the mighty smoke because it's
not as bad as you say not sometimes all
the times you don't look very healthy do
you take vitamins i take drugs those are
Clemens
you have a girlfriend it's because you
don't look maybe can you please finish
up feeding or it could be because the
bed I don't have the bad breath smoking
is one of the leading causes of ginger
legs really giving me a headache right
now and take very good care giving me a
huge migraine headache you should get a
girlfriend to take care good for kids
clearly can't take care of yourself
yes Abdul young turn over man
what does this mean EDX Tillich Aqualad
pathetic fallen beginner lindakhaas of
each motoko s turkey composition
practically a combinar see to say angst
an LED it is a posse and forum but an
energy okay did my expert at the covino
cosmic miss Manette ax murder I can go
out at Blair I'm there but my room so
vast out a not leave a mini rex the
beach bulik taken over all that later
the pen the economy the virus coordinate
from the door clatters in
look to it the Harmony attacks
borivali Oh school will fit you oh no no
stop i'm sure you're more deceptive wave
of bossy who's gonna fear just don't
worry offense yeah um yunkish go right
back ah don't let supercell feel dizzy
no yeah baby yeah yep
sixty Ramon necessarily then induces fo
Oh
you
Simunic money that's in
bgm wall was that the exception a good
at see me
hey Lisa spirit even if we set chingon
balti good
you
Holly who should you fish for book
toothless 500 foxbat possum are you
passionately Natalie oh ye
I would like to invite our next group of
creators up to the stage please
hey awesome yeah awesome
all right congratulations to our
nominees great movies very powerful very
beautiful so thank you um so I would
like to ask a general question to begin
with what appealed to you about the
short form medium and and making a short
what was it about it that that made you
decide to make one of these sure well in
this case it was putting a lens on
Somalia difficult place i would say
probably not the commercially biggest
film market in the US and to try to give
some insight into their world so there
was no better place to start i think
with a short which could sort of open
that world up to people to see great
well when we can see this idea my
colleague and friend Martin rose in the
audience tonight came over yeah came to
Afghanistan to visit me I've been in
there since 2008 and I'd seen a country
I did not expect that I hadn't seen on
the news and so we ran around and put
all these locations in Kabul and decided
to write a film and this film sort of
poured out of us and it was a small
story about two kids coming of age and
we consider doing a feature but we
thought that you know due to logistical
challenges which I'll let my incredible
producer Ariel here talk about we
thought that you know taking a short
film and making that well was better
than trying to bite off more than we
could chew so we we were already being
over our heads so we we thought we'd try
and keep it keep it short and see what
we could pull off we didn't know what we
could what we could do there it was an
experiment and
so we thought this was the right way to
get into it okay well the reason that I
we made a short film was because it was
all we can afford I mean I can't really
afford to go much beyond 20 minutes for
what we're doing my producer Damon
Russell is here and he's he's fantastic
we've done a couple short films together
and curfew was something that was
important to to me to tell and he said
he said I don't think you should do it
for a variety of reasons it was going to
be tough to pull off but we did it and
that's that's something that I think
will will be proud of because it I don't
know if it can really be a feature so
short film is is good for what it is
especially if it's called curfew right
exactly you only got a 10 home early
yeah you know yeah I think for me it was
also a bit finding the challenge to tell
a story in 20 minutes we thought it was
dead of a shadow and trying to convey
this certain emotion is certain story
but in a short amount of time and which
was a very challenging to thing to do
create a little world in in 20 minutes
is a feat that you have to really work
at and a lot of people here are very
accomplished in that and I hope at least
we could do that bit is fill with the
challenge to tell this story which was a
bit complex to some extent but also
something that I felt could be told in
20 minutes and not more so that's why
every shows a short phone yeah and as
far as Henry is concerned well the point
of view that I wanted to show from
Henry's point of view of Alzheimer's and
all I thought when I started writing it
it sort of completed itself just that
aspect of it and in about twenty one
minutes and and like Sean said also
everything was you know sort of coming
out of my own pocket so feature would
have been quiet it was already it was
already a huge challenge to to make this
film and it was a lot of fun but to tell
the story the way that I wanted it for
from this aspect from that point of view
I sort of a I said what I wanted to say
in about twenty one minutes um I have
this is a might seem like a dumb
question because it's get specific to a
couple of you but as an actor I'm
curious like for you guys what was it
like working with actors who were
speaking in acting in a foreign language
how were you as directors able to tell
what what was you know if I am not sure
if you speak the languages but but just
besides that how it was you know it's
very hard to direct any way and I an act
at everything and I can't imagine what
it's like to do it crossing over those
language barriers I think it's sooo
crevasse Lee it was incredible and I
just want know what it was like for you
what your experience was like um it was
uh yeah it was pretty scary I mean we
really didn't know until we finally
finished the Edit if they were just
lying to us the whole time no um the co
there was like all right these guys are
showing up and they're shooting okay um
no we you know you it's sort of
interesting um this is it in the soup
yeah exactly our mother just saying
nothing here gibberish on the the
you know it's interesting we got into it
I mean there were many obstacles I'm
sure you were into the obstacles to obey
obviously working with there was no
actors there so they're all refugees
there was translators weren't film
translators they're just somebody who
can do both languages basically and then
you have the complex issue of their
language isn't as long as our language
so when I'm just you your your sort of
you've written longer but it said faster
and you're like reading back and forth
on the script guy hey what line are they
on you know like I can't figure on the
[ __ ] out and then you're just going back
and forth back and forth so it took us
rehearsal so many rehearsals you know
over and over again to study were they
was it locked in to where it should be
and our two leads the two lead boys
heard this but they were illiterate so
they memorized the whole script so they
it was such an undertaking with them
which I didn't we didn't see coming but
it did allow me because I was illiterate
to basically that I could practice with
them watching the lines going jumping
back and forth rehearsing rehearsing and
then finally getting to the point where
we could actually go out and shoot the
thing so that was the that was the key I
guess you know you had a really really
study what was going on action vs words
Wow incredible yeah we actually had the
opposite problem in dotty they speak
longer than we do so it's to say hi and
bye you know Uncle vis lives in a house
it's like five sentences but um we been
living and working there for since he
doesn't eight doing documentaries and
actually my dog is not as good as it
should be Ariel has been at the same
time and he speaks fluently but uh our
entire project was conceived as a as a
training project from the very beginning
so we actually spent a year in
pre-production and we try we brought in
for the filmmakers over in trained a
whole Afghan crew so I had we had some
great people working with us afghan my
directors training was fantastic and he
you know we were training with him
during the rehearsal process we actually
sat with kids won't actually our lead
actor for what the blacksmith's son in
BOS Kashi boys was actually a street kid
when we end up casting him because again
you can't find
child actors it's very hard you can't
just put ad in backstage Wes and
expecting you know in the show of
traditions so we were lucky to find Xiao
and marred who was a son of whatever
very famous film directors and there's a
group of them have been around since in
70s so we're lucky very lucky to find
him but for WOD was a street kid and it
was very hard to well not hard but the
idea was to make him not act but
actually just be himself because he
inhabited the character so we spent
three weeks in intensive rehearsals and
actually wrote the dialogue with the
kids so we were all on the same page
during the production but yeah I was
definitely a challenge doing in the
foreign language but Martin Martin and I
wrote the script so that it could be I
hopefully visual and since and show the
story visually so yeah showed you that
as well well no but it's it's great
because you know all of the films except
try me and take place in other countries
well New York is another country yes
sorry good yes that's true that's true
so they all these so these are all
foreign yeah they're all four cents yeah
that's correct yeah well this is a see
you guys got more than you realize
tonight is the foreign live action short
night symposium but what do you and what
is it like like Tom overseas in Belgium
what it what does it mean to you and
what does it say to you about short film
and you know globally and what does it
feel like over there and what has been
the response back home for you well I
have to speak for the whole nation so uh
yeah what is the voice of Belgium's
generation have the source of Belgium
yeah oh I think what's happening in
Belgium is very very it's a very good
time in Pro Belgian film because not
only I with the Oscar nomination but
every person every young person all the
people who are doing short films are
accomplishing a lot doing a lot of
festivals they're winning a lot of
prices a lot of talent there I think
it's really a new point in our cinema
and we've reached that we actually can
break through internationally as well
and I hope to be part of that in a
little little sense but I think it's a
good time for us as Belgians to be part
of the world cinema yeah cool yeah what
about you what about me no no I mean it
but you yeah yeah i mean it's it's uh
actually the cool i think it's a cool
thing the past three years there's been
a french canadian film nominated for
best foreign films and and again this
year and there was it all started with
mr. daniel a couple years back and it
seems like the there are lots of you
know they're all extremely talented the
crew and all and as far as my my short
is concerned because i've been part of
this sort of a world since I was eight
years old back in Canada sort of asked
the Astra favors and ask people to if
they wanted to jump on board and and so
they they were extremely generous to
sort of i give me their talent and get
on this journey of telling the story of
henry which was a very personal story
link to related to my grandfather in
all's and so it's uh but I mean Canada
and in in Quebec in this case has been
there's extremely talented directors and
there's a lot of amazing directors that
I can look up to and look at their work
and and and be influenced by them and
and but I think also as far as short
Spencer short films are concerned the
great thing is is that with the with the
Oscars right now all of our short films
are being screened yeah all around the
world and it's an amazing thing for
short films because some people aren't
necessarily um they don't necessarily
know much about short films but it's
it's fun because you can go and you go
you know it lasts for about two hours
say just warm program you've got five
short films and you go through different
worlds and and just like denied with the
same thing with the animation but say
for a live-action shorts you go from one
that is
like toms film where it's more sci-fi
with amazing visual effects and all of
that or and and you go to curfew and
then you go to Assad then you go to
busch Kashi boys it's all different
worlds and and and this is all in about
two hours that you're actually traveling
through these different worlds and
stories and I think that's it's all good
for it's amazing for shorts and because
there are lots of short films being made
all around the world and not just 125
that were submitted this year but
they're like 10 to 20,000 short films
being made every year and and so I think
it's just if this can also gives a good
sort of a diving board to all great
filmmakers it's it's a great thing no I
was in I was in New York Sean I was in
New York last week and it was and it was
freezing cold snowing there was a storm
and I walked past the IFC theater where
they were playing this package of films
and there was a line outside it was so
cool so incredible to see like you know
and it's true what you're saying I think
because of you know these awards and
everyone being nominated the great thing
is the package and people getting to see
the movies on the big screen to which is
so powerful and incredible and yeah so
that's great and you know Sean like did
you do some of the music for your movie
yeah yeah yeah the the bowling alley
scene where she's dance yeah yeah I had
to do that out of necessity the band
that wanted we had a song from a band a
smallish ban actually that was going to
be there and all the extras had to and
I'm not gonna say with ban
and now I said because they would love
that but they wouldn't let's have the
song maybe if you slipped me twenty
dollars after the time okay they wanted
more money than was the entire music
budget for their fell out with her song
and I just couldn't do it and so one of
my producers Andrew Napier who's here
tonight he was like listen just shoot
all the extras dancing to that their
song and then record another song later
and I was a great idea and then I shot
the movie and it was a disaster because
I had to get that song out of my head I
had to do a song that was in the same
tempo as their song it had to be a song
that some kid would want to jump up and
dance to and it was kind of a nightmare
and it only lasts the minute that's on
the film there is no ending or middle
Wow yeah oh it's just absolute is that
yeah just kind of fades out like two
seconds after that lyrics either there's
nothing I'm just mumbling that's amazing
that is so funny that is so funny oh my
god no all the music is so great in all
of the all of the the movies and that is
ultimate is also so diverse I mean it's
just incredible who were the composers
of your of your of your film the music
throughout the film is marcel Khalife
he's a lebanese composure and his the
album and the excerpts from it are
called tech ism so we just our editor
actually found him he cut to the music
and we loved it so much we just canceled
her aunt he's a current yeah yeah I mean
I mean that was interesting is Chris
Franklin just went through the dailies
and he just put in music randomly that
day that was that track Wow yeah that
was it you know so beautiful so
effective and powerful say what about
you yeah we were incredibly lucky to
have a composer named Jim Dooley and do
our our music and is he here tonight not
but he I mean he he just he went way
under market for us and helped us out
and we did a lot of a lot of cues like
we we we really we worked in very worked
very hard so no was it was great it was
really a gift for a film yeah he was
amazing a composer of death of a shadow
was a rough Coonan and he's also the one
who made the score for bullhead was a
last year nominated as a foreign
language film here at the Oscars Wow and
during the process of the making the
music we actually used instruments who
are kind of rare called crystal Bechet
and Aunt Martha know and use a special
specialist musician for that Thomas
block who works with Radiohead and
things like that and we were very
fortunate to work with him and we were
kind of looking for music that was
actually only available during that
period and a funny thing with those kind
of engine instruments people actually
sometimes went mad when they heard them
so if i do some did some lasting damage
today I'm sorry for that wow that's so
funny messy on yeah did he do a lot of
music with owens martin no mess i yawn
the composer I'm sorry that was a that
wasn't supposed to be out loud it was
your inside voice jay-z I sorry I'm
sorry guys I gotta switch that I have I
have an internal monologue button that I
forgot to hit um and what about you jaan
because the music obviously is a huge
part of you yeah mine is a huge part
where right from the start from day one
when I started writing the the film
because i wanted i wanted for i wanted
music to be sort of a beacon of light
for for Henry which was he's looking
he's searching for his wife but
and this is part of Alzheimer's as well
and dementia sometimes if if you know
someone who who has that illness it's
weird but I was told many stories where
that person wouldn't recognize you but
if that person would start to hear a
music that would relate to his past boom
he would come back and and so that from
the mount from day one when I started
writing the film there was the cavaletti
a toasty Ghana which is the other mask
anyone and that I wanted in the that I
wanted in the film just because I had
heard it before and I sort of resonated
with me and funny enough because this is
sort of a related to my grandfather on
my mother's side when I had my mom read
the script when she read the script and
she saw that it wasn't the Kebra dairy
Aroostook Anna was in the and the script
she said funny enough you didn't know
that but your grandfather actually loved
that song and even though he was in a
musician it was like oh ok this is a
nice beautiful coincidence and so there
was that and there was a Schumann as
well in this is when Maria and young
Henry and young Maria meet for the first
time and and I was always looking for
duets and my even though those those
pieces aren't duits at first but my
musician my music composer Alexis said
anime from Montreal I had worked with
him on my first short and he was like
okay let's will will will make it will
make it happen as a duet in and it's and
it's will create it and we'll do the
arrangements and all and so it was an
amazing word from from them and then
obviously the my actors also could could
play for real which helped a lot in
really yeah and then obviously
afterwards you go in recording session
and then to just to improve it because
there's so many different you know here
things here and there during the
shooting days but my actors that's one
of the other things that I wanted was
for them to be especially the young ones
to be as real realistic as possible in
the music was a what it's a beacon of
light so the beacon that directs Henry
towards I guess were looking for his
wife and yeah towards the end of the
film okay well I'm going to ask one last
question
so you know I think that you're all
incredible and you will go well first of
all I will tell you this is an internal
monologue thing but this is such a crazy
feeling for actor to be with the
directors looking at him and I'm asking
you the questions yeah this is a great
feeling i must tell you that and like
downstairs you guys were so excited and
some seem nervous I was like a haha this
is great this is so unusual and I really
I don't want it to end but it has been a
long night but I must say selfishly is
really one it's really you see what it's
like to be like a huge like to be one of
the big stars maybe that makes a
director nervous like you know I'm one
of the couple out there make some it's
pretty great but so my last question is
I do think you're all wonderful and
hopefully will go on to have super long
careers and all types of mediums do you
think that you would does the short film
medium is it does it something that you
feel like you you would like to revisit
at some point in your lives i'm sure
it's a obviously crazy question ask now
but do you could you see that happening
would you ever come back if you went on
to make longer movies would you ever
yeah i think short films are really fun
to make feel like the one thing that's
great about them and what makes them
accessible for everyone is the pressure
of having to make a film that's going to
make money is off because you're not
gonna make any money so you really have
to come up with a short that you want
people to see and love for what it is so
i think definitely it was a great
experience and I follow cuz I'm a
commercial director so you get down to
30 seconds you make a lot of money so um
so you know there's that that side of
things to you know you just shrink it
down enough put a couple in 22 states in
there boom your gold I guess you know
but it's but that long yeah it is it's
an amazing format to get stuff and to
get things made like said I mean look at
our films right now I you know it would
be extremely difficult to convince
anybody to go off and make a film about
two boys in Afghanistan rich boys and
Somalia or the life of somebody in
Somalia and and that there's no other
way and yes I mean I can see diving into
other worlds that means crazy as New
York I mean I wouldn't go there no um
but I mean you can just go explore a
world it's amazing you know yeah amazing
that's the thing about short films as
you can experiment excited exactly
you're saying and I just want to say
also its absolute honor to be up here
with you guys I mean I'm your films are
absolutely thank you so I mean it's just
something here inside voices and the
inside voice but uh but um you know you
can experiment with a short film you
don't know I mean I want to do I mean I
wouldn't make feature films but I mean
this is a thing you can you can go out
on a limb and make something you know it
did no one's gonna pay you for but that
you care about a lot you know and I
think both Harry and I wouldn't would
say that you know it's appealing to be
able to take a risk and not risk that
much money so yeah that's what I like
about it I would love to make a short
film again but my wife told me I'm never
allowed to because put some money into
it and it took a lot out of me and she
looked at me afterwards and I said do
you like it and she said yes and I said
what are you thinking she said you're
never allowed to do that again so if i
do shoot a short film which i'm sure i
will it'll be behind her back and you
know i'll be on the phone in the
bathroom like okay get the gaffer
okay that kind of thing like who you on
the phone with nobody nobody honey I
agree that is it's a really great medium
to experiment especially for younger
people also I mean what we see in
Belgium is that it's basically really a
starting point to have a sort of real or
a showreel to then go towards feature
films so that's basically the the way it
goes in Belgium at the moment well for
me at the moment because it took five
years for me to make this film didn't
seem that appealing to go back to hahaha
so I hope but I think it's always going
to be a very interesting format to work
with because sometimes it's even more
difficult to tell a story in such a
short amount of time than it is in the
feature and so such a challenge if it
does appeal to to make something like
that and to put yourself through that
process to get something told in such a
limited amount of time and I don't know
if you want to revisit it just now but
maybe in a couple of years yeah and then
we'll see cool yeah i mean it's it's I
think I'd love to sort of next step yeah
director feature but I think also that
the great thing about shorts is actually
you're telling a story and same thing
with the feature but if say there's
something that comes out I'm like oh I
want to tell this story then but it's a
15 minute long story or if it's a 12
minute long story then you know I'll
sort of have to get it out and write it
down and and try to try to make it but
it's it's as everyone we've all said
pretty much the same thing about shorts
it's extremely Amy it's it's all you're
on your own and you've got your crew and
people are just jumping in with their
generosity and their extreme talent in
it it's a you know it's the same process
to make a short than it is to make a
feature except that you know instead of
having like 30 days 30 days shoot you
might have just five days shoe
thing you know so but it's it's very
appealing format or way of making films
and try to tell story in a really short
amount of time but if the story needs to
be told in that amount of time then I
think that's what it is you know so it's
and then feature film so it's I think
it's so it's all a creative process and
it's that's what's so beautiful about
cinema is you can make short stories and
you can make long stories and they're
all beautiful well I want to say before
we go because of this event i went and
on the internet and the animated shorts
directors and all of you guys i've seen
so much great there's so much that
they've all done or and great interviews
they've given and tumblers and I mean
all just great stuff that you should I
encourage everyone to go see because
this is just the beginning there's so
much great stuff so I want to thank
everyone for coming and staying I know
it's been a great long night but it's
been affirming and it's been a
celebration of movies and
congratulations to all of our all of our
nominees you guys all are the best so
have a good night rock on